United States that country's registered
the world's largest number of deaths in
a single day more than two thousand died
there on Friday bringing the country's
total to almost nineteen thousand among
efforts to try to cope with the rising
number of bodies dozens of refrigerated
trucks have been parked up now ready to
be used as makeshift morgues one doctor
working in the Bronx told us his
experience fighting coronaviruses worse
he said than tackling Ebola I mean the
epicenter of the epicenter of the
epicenter Anam with colleagues are from
different parts of the world giving
their all every day and night I grew up
in Nigeria I was born and raised and
also trained there and I experienced the
Ebola Ebola period but this is crazier
than what I could have ever imagined the
change of experience with this pandemic
has been is that feeling of helplessness
sometimes like the fact that you've done
all you can do and you still get the
negative outcome from this in my
personal experience it was I would say
moderate symptoms I was quarantined for
more than seven days at least seven days
and it was scary the major part of this
experience was fear and we would have
seen on the hospital and with the cases
I've seen seen young people die from
this you know I think there was a very
large component of here for me because
there are two ways you can go you can
get better or you could go to that I see
you and get intubated and probably die
from this and that was the fear part but
I know I'm a man of faith so I as much
as possible just try to put things to
God's hand and I got healed
you're the best juicer well health
workers arguably risk the most exposure
to the coronavirus hospital staff in New
York held a vigil on Friday for
colleagues who lost their lives fighting
the pandemic RT Americans Trinity Chavez
has more on the strain the city's
hospitals are under right now today New
York City the crossroads of the world
has more confirmed cases of covin 19
than any other city on earth hospitals
still hitting capacity and medical staff
pushed to their brink everything we're
trying pre-hospital e we're giving our
all but really every EMT and paramedic
in this city right now
he's giving more than they ever have
while the US Navy hospital ship comfort
and the Javits Center are supposed to
help alleviate stress off the city's
hospital system the 500 bed vessel
comfort just has over 60 patients while
the 1,000 bed convention center field
hospital has seen about 225 patients new
reports suggesting the Army and the Navy
are handpicking and transporting small
numbers of hospital patients while the
virus continues to strain
ER rooms first responders also on the
frontlines the FDNY reporting that
nearly 400 EMS workers including
firefighters tested positive for the
corona virus we've dealt with large
scale events before but we haven't dealt
with a sustained serious call volume now
going on its third week with no end in
sight and roughly 3,000 of the
department's 15,000 were out sick I hate
the phrase we know what we signed up for
as much as we may have known we didn't
know this we haven't seen this
but we know why we signed up for this
but perhaps some hope the governor now
saying the curve is slowing while the
curve may be leveling off the city is
still dealing with the mounting
coronavirus death toll the National
Guard now using rental vans to pick up
hundreds of dead bodies from New York
City homes mork space in the city
dwindling the city now using an island
off the Bronx waters called Hart island
as a temporary burial site an aerial
view shows hired contractors wearing
protective gear digging graves and
lining up dozens of caskets in those
deep trenches under a new policy the
Medical Examiner's Office will keep
bodies in storage for 14 days before
they're buried in Hart Islands potter's
field which is a burial site for people
whose families can't afford a funeral or
who go unclaimed by relatives the number
of burials increasing from about 25 a
week to now 24 a day reporting in New
York Trinity Chavez Artie
you